thanks to curiositystream and nebula for
sponsoring this video
there's something rather special about
the lab that i'm standing in right now
there's some amazing science experiments
behind me but that's not what makes this
place unique what makes this place
unique
is
what's above us it's an interesting
place and it's very difficult to
describe so you go down this cage and it
takes about seven or eight minutes and
then you're a kilometer underground when
people hear the word mine they think of
i don't know mine's in cornwall small
mines you crawl into baubie is nothing
like that it's huge roadways a thousand
kilometers of roadways cut into this
sort that are so big you can drive a
truck down them it's very salty it's
very dark it's very dry and all those
things give this place a very
otherworldly feel about it you know you
crunch along these tunnels to the
underground lab so you walk through this
very dirty dusty source of that so this
very high tech laboratory it's looking
for dark matter where we do some
astrobiology research and that's the
environment you're in it's an almost
alien environment almost like you would
expect being in a laboratory
on mars would be like disconnected from
the rest of the world
i am 1.1 kilometers under yorkshire in
the north of england at the bolby
underground lab
we exist 1.1 kilometers underground in
this mine here at bulby so the lab here
has existed since the 1990s and
originally a professor from sheffield
university
wanted an underground space to really
start to understand dark matter they
approached the mine and asked basically
can we have some space underground to do
a little bit of science and the mine
were like yeah that'll be fine they you
know they didn't particularly understand
what was going on but it wasn't very
invasive the lab here is is built to
host science from collaborations all
over the world one of the things we can
boast in is that we have a very broad
science program so most underground labs
in the world exist for particle physics
but we we have really established
ourselves as a multi-disciplinary lab we
have amazing environmental science that
goes on we've got the
space technology we've got the
astrobiology work that goes on and
really interesting geological science as
well although some of the other
underground labs are now exploring those
avenues we really paved the way for that
here at bulby
my name is ed banks my job title here is
facility science support technician
which i think has at least one too many
words essentially what that means is
that i am the on-site lead for various
experiments the actual science is owned
by various institutions universities
businesses and they send the science to
us and we run it for them remotely to be
honest i absolutely love it it's not far
from probably a dream job for me getting
to work with
different types of science every day is
amazing so the first thing that you need
to do is get kitted out in mine gear
because it is an active mine and we're
going to be walking through that so you
have your full orange overalls hard hat
safety boots all that sort of stuff um
you then go to the mine building where
you pass through a series of air locks
and this is because there's a huge
overpressure needed to ventilate the
massive tunnel system uh you then get
into the lift which is not an ordinary
lift that you might find in a building
it's a three-story cage
where
some of the walls kind of has have gaps
you can see through to the the tunnel
outside the the cage as we call it then
takes seven minutes to descend the 1.1
kilometers to the level of the mine uh
once you are there you then have to walk
through the tunnels to the lab and
that's just over half a kilometer takes
about 10 minutes
yeah it does feel otherworldly
definitely like walking through the
tunnels and the temperature the dust in
the air like just the texture of the
ground is weird like it's not something
that you used to
feels very strange sometimes a lifelong
ambition of mine has been to be
an astronaut and i've imagined myself
walking on the moon countless times
but
i think this may be the closest i ever
get to actually walking on the moon's
surface it really does feel like we're
exploring the ruins of some
old alien civilization on a distant
planet
this industry that's just coated in a
thick layer of fine powder once you
reach the entrance of the lab you have
to then get clean because you've walked
through a dirty mine so you have to get
changed into the white overalls that you
can see us wearing now different hard
hats we have dirty ones for the tunnel
and clean ones for inside and then you
can come in and do whatever science it
is that you're here to do
so in the background of some of this
video you may hear what sounds like
dance music and it's dance music at
precisely 60 beats a minute
it's not that
it is
behind me
the liquid nitrogen plant so liquid
nitrogen is used in a bunch of science
experiments to cool components down
normally you just sort of ship it in but
because this is a kilometer below ground
that's a little inconvenient so
they make their own here and it just so
happens the machine operates
as emma said a whole range of
interesting sciences done down here but
of particular interest to me was the
research relating to space exploration
and specifically exobiology because for
very specific reasons this mine is a
very good approximation to the red
planet it's shockingly similar to mars
in some ways
i often hear people ask like if you're
doing space research have you not gone
the wrong way because obviously you know
we're underground we believe that on
mars there used to be surface water we
haven't found liquid water yet there's
ice at the poles and but we believe
there used to be surface water features
that have at some distant point in the
past evaporated
so those kind of conditions are
the same as what led to the formation of
the salt in the caverns here so you know
ancient sea evaporated left behind some
salt if there are caverns in that salt
on mars in the just below the surface
and then that would make this even
closer to the sort of conditions that
we'd expect it does feel a little bit
childish sometimes of look at this cool
rock i found but
pretty much a pure salt crystal so what
information about the life that existed
in the ancient sea
can you infer from what's left in the
salt
um
you can like directly look for these
microorganisms oh really almost like an
amber
sort of yeah so one of like the kinds of
experiments that they do is you have
little hammers and you crack open the
rock and then you
put the samples on your microscope and
look for microorganisms
straightforward is that so in some cases
they are like still visible even after
230 million years to find out more i
spoke to professor charles kirkel at the
university of edinburgh who has
performed experiments in astrobiology at
the bulby mine i mean astrobiology some
people think it's looking for aliens
but but astrobiology
is simply looking at biology in its
cosmic context and i know it sounds a
bit strange what i mean by that is it's
also looking at the history of life on
earth we don't have to go and look for
alien life to know there is life on this
planet that's fairly uncontroversial and
so how did it get here and how has it
been around for four and a half billion
years and what is the future of life on
this planet bobby is is
you know a kilometer or more of of salt
and there's no such environment anywhere
actually else elsewhere in the solar
system ironically but um having said
that if you go down into ball b minor
kilometer underground what you will find
is trickles of water seeping through
those ancient salt deposits quarter of a
billion years old and those very salty
deposits are similar to what we do
observe or what we think we observe on
mars and some people think that even in
the present day
there is briny water seeping out from
the subsurface of mars into craters and
so those brines in bourbon might be
similar to the sorts of environments
that existed on mars some of these
brines in baubie if they flow through
the wrong type of salt like magnesium
chloride they develop chemical
conditions that completely prevent the
growth of life so in other words if you
go into one place in bourbon you'll find
brine seeps that are full of life and
then if that brine
goes slightly in the wrong direction
passes through magnesium chloride the
water activity or the availability of
water becomes so low that no life can
grow in that brine and as a consequence
it's completely lifeless it can inform
where you might want to go and look for
life uh it can inform how you might look
for life in those brains let's say that
i gave you a sample of a brine on mars
you know how would you get biological
information out of that brian first
thing i would just stick it under a
microscope so i'm a bit old school like
that you know microbes are easy to see
under a good microscope so if it was a
modern brine that's the first thing i
would do i would stain it maybe with
some
stain that binds to
nucleic acids or proteins and i would
put it under a microscope and see
whether i see little glowing dots then i
would try various chemical extractions
to see whether i could extract dna or
dna like molecules or proteins and then
i might try and look at the lipids the
sorts of things that make up cell
membranes so by looking at the sorts of
life that exists in
martian brines we can get some ideas
about the limits of life on mars and
what might have limited life there but
it's as i say also about trying to
understand the fundamentals you know how
does life adapt to extreme environments
and and what sort of planetary
environments can it live in
and and what sort of environments is it
excluded from and these are interesting
questions purely from a from a
biological point of view as well as the
practical point of view of looking for
life on mars i find it fascinating that
in order to explore other planets we
find alien worlds on our own planet and
after thousands or tens of thousands of
years of habitation we're still finding
these environments that are maybe just a
few kilometers away from what we think
of as our home planet
and that are a lot easier to return from
than mars i don't know if you can hear
this but there's we're walking into
quite a headwind at the moment and
that's because
the mine has to have its air pumped in
right so there's a system
where the air flows in
circulates around and then flows out so
the outflow is really hot and i was just
told
that if you're lost if your light dies
or whatever
good tip
walk into the wind
because it means
you're near
the exit shaft
bulby hosts many fascinating research
projects martian exobiology being just
one of them another key area of study
one kilometer below the earth's surface
is dark matter but what is this stuff
and how are physicists at bolby trying
to find it
well i've made a whole second video
about that over on nebula nebula which
recently passed half a million paying
users is the streaming service owned and
operated by a collection of educational
youtubers here you can watch our videos
without ads on the website or in the
videos as well as additional original
content such as my videos on dark matter
and how norway became the electric
vehicle capital of the world but there's
also original series such as the battle
of britain by real engineering or modern
conflicts by real life law to get access
to nebula you can sign up with our
partners curiosity stream the largest
source of high quality documentaries on
the web if you enjoyed this video then
perhaps you'll enjoy the mini series on
curiosity stream becoming martian about
the history and future of martian
exploration if nebula is the best of
your favorite indie creators on youtube
then curiosity stream is the best of big
budget productions and stars like david
attenborough and hannah frye you can get
access to both with our bundle deal
available at curiositystream.com
simon clark for 26
off a mere 14.79 a year or a little over
one dollar a month
that's a dollar a month for the version
of youtube you already watch but with
more content and no ads and a lifetime
supply of engaging educational content
it may be the best investment you ever
make in your online experience that's
curiositystream.com simon clark with
thanks to curiositystream and nebula for
sponsoring this video
thank you for watching the video all the
way through i really hoped you enjoyed
this one i hope that it communicated
just how much of an amazing alien
experience it was to go to bolby i had a
fantastic time making this video if you
wanted some recommendations on youtube
then here's some other stuff from me you
can also sign up to curiositystream and
nebula with one of the links below me
and the other one is to subscribe to
this channel that just leaves me now to
say thank you so much again for watching
if you enjoyed the video please do pop
it a like and share it with people that
you think may also be interested
thanks again i'll see you in the next
one